Please help me welcome David.
He won't
[inaudible].
Hello everybody.
I am David.
He Walt.
I'm a tech journalist and author of a couple of bucks.
It's good to be back here at Google again.
I was here a couple of years ago for my first book,
which was about Dungeons and dragons.
And now I'm writing about virtual reality.
So I am a giant nerd.
I'm one of you.
Um,
I'm so,
I'm excited to be back here,
but frankly I'm a little worried because I've just written a book that's a
history of virtual reality and talking about like where this new generation of
products came from and here I am at Google.
So I kind of feel like lecturing Googlers about VR would be like going to like
Le Cordon Bleu and lecturing them about how to make an Omelette.
I'm not super comfortable about that.
So there's a couple of different things I want to talk about.
Um,
when I give talks at other venues,
I usually give very sort of,
I started out very elementary.
It's a sort of like what is virtual reality?
I know you guys know what is virtual reality.
So here I'm going to skip some of the basics.
I want to instead focus on supplying some context about talking about the bigger
picture of where virtual reality came from and that leads into some reasons why
virtual reality is important,
not just to businesses but to humanity as a whole.
Um,
so we'll start that with a brief and highly abridged history of virtual worlds.
I take history pretty seriously.
So when I talk about history,
I'm really looking at them going way far back.
Um,
this is about 17,000 years back.
humans have been trying to create virtual realities for a very long time.
Uh,
basically for as long as we've had technology,
we've been trying to use that technology to escape the real world and enter
fantasy worlds.
This is Lascaux cave.
This is from a subterranean complex in the southwestern part of France.
And in these caves,
some of the first modern humans in Europe decorated these caverns with hundreds
of pictures of animals and symbols and abstract shapes.
And from here,
and just looking at it as a,
as a photograph,
it looks like just scribblings on the wall.
But when you stand inside these caves,
it becomes clear that these creators were actually creating a virtual world.
Think of it this way,
just like when you put on a virtual reality headset,
part of the reason why you have that headset is because it's blocking out the
world around you.
It's closing off this lecture room.
It's that you're only paying attention to the screen in front of you.
That's what these caves did.
You would go down into these caves from the valley above and you're no longer in
the woods.
You're no longer in this,
in this beautiful part of France,
in this specific space where they have painted this stuff.
The walls created this imagery around you and the idea was that the caves
themselves are the immersive environment.
These animals would surround you there in your face and the artists use all
kinds of prospective tricks to actually make them seem alive.
So instead of just being,
this is just kind of a profile of a,
of a bowl or have an aurochs.
Some of the pictures,
the head of the bowl would be turned towards the viewer.
Other ones like you can see him if cave entrance.
Some of the paintings actually have the both start on one wall and turn the
corner.
So it seems like the animal is actually moving.
And so they used all these tricks to make the scene come a lot.
The author and the technologist Howard Rheingold calls this subterranean
cyberspace and I think that's pretty accurate because what the people who
created this we're probably trying to do was to imprint information onto the
minds of the people viewing it.
The idea being that like,
okay,
we need to teach young people what it's like to go on the hunt to be surrounded
by these deadly animals.
So you could take them down in the caves and show them like this is what it
looks like.
These are where the animals are.
Or maybe it had some sort of religious function or something like that.
But the idea always being this is the experience.
This is what it's like to be surrounded by these animals.
So eventually the caveman left their caves.
So this is sort of the next step of Lascaux cave is when we look at things like
this.
Um,
this is,
um,
the great theater of Ephesus in Turkey.
Um,
this was constructed around 2100 years ago and the word theater in ancient Greek
actually kind of translates to viewer.
So this was an ancient VR viewer.
The idea here was not just,
Oh,
this is a platform for a play.
The idea was that they were using the most cutting edge technology available to
them at the time to immerse people in whatever play,
whatever presentation they were doing on that stage.
They have the semicircular amphitheater.
That was because that shape amplifies sound waves.
So you could have one little guy now on stage and all the thousands of people in
the seats could hear what he was saying.
They used mechanical devices that a thing called a Mecca [inaudible],
which looks sort of like a Trevis Shay.
It had like levers and wires and stuff and the McCain would lift actors up into
the air and make it look like they were flying.
If you ever heard of the expression,
the dues ex Machina,
that's actually where that comes from.
The machine is the mecking.
They used elaborate props and costumes and settings and and and backdrops in
front of the play with the whole idea being,
we're going to create this immersive environment and the people in the audience
aren't just going to think that they're watching some people on a stage.
They're going to think they're here in this fantasy world.
So these audiences,
these performances really audiences into a simulated environment.
Another way to do that is with art.
This was a 10th century painting on 11 foot wide scroll.
It's called the night revels of hand.
She's die and according to legend,
this is a record of an actual night in the life of a bureaucrat and he was
legendary legendarily just like Debachi's bus.
He was collecting taxes or whatever,
just spending on parties and on women and music and whatever.
And the emperor started to get upset about this.
He was like,
I want to know what that guy's doing.
So he commissioned this painting.
He sent a painter to one of these parties and said,
create this long scroll,
show me exactly what this scumbag is up to.
So it's a 10 sensor equivalent of like setting up Paparazzi to a party or
something.
It was really about like,
I want this thing so I can surround myself with it.
I can be immersed and really see what's happening at these madcap parties.
Other artists took that idea even further.
So this is,
uh,
a panorama.
This was created by a artists,
Robert Baker,
who was an Irishman.
He created this and around 1801,
and you can see that this is just a massive payment.
He did these things,
three stories tall and what he would do is create these giant landscapes and
build a custom building and wrap the landscape around the walls of the building.
So people would enter and stand in the middle and it would feel like they're on
the coast of Scotland or they're in the middle of London or something like that.
Um,
he patented technique as the Panorama.
They built these things all over Scotland and London and even a couple,
uh,
in other countries around the world,
there were immensely popular tourist attractions,
uh,
because they were so immersive at the time when newspapers wrote about these
immersive paintings,
some of them actually said,
this is an alternative.
The travel,
we don't ever need to go anywhere again because we can do this.
You can see what it's like out there in the,
in the real world.
And it's funny to read those old newspaper stories because they read a lot.
Like some of the newspaper stories I've seen in the last couple of years about
Vr,
especially if you look at like the press releases released by like hotel chains
that have done VR apps and stuff like that.
They're like,
oh,
come see what our hotel is like and stuff like that.
You can experience the world just like you,
you could,
if you're actually there,
obviously it's not as good as the real thing,
but for the time this was really immersive.
This was virtual reality for them.
The next way to create a virtual realities was by transporting audiences and to
immersing them into their subject matter using optics,
not art.
The first real generation of VR manufacturers were opticians.
They were not artists,
and that was because of a particular phenomenon that makes VR possible.
Uh,
take a second,
everybody close your left eye and look at me through your right eye and then
close your right eye and look at me left and go back and forth like this.
Now,
one reason I do that is because it's really funny to me to see a whole bunch of
people do that at once.
But what you're seeing there is everything sort of shifts from one eye to the
other.
Um,
that's called parallax.
It's because your eyes are slightly spaced apart,
so they each have a slightly different view of the world.
Your brain takes that information.
It knows,
okay,
left,
I saw this here,
right?
I saw this here.
And it uses that data to calculate depth and distance based on just the triangle
eye to eye,
to whatever you're there.
Your brain does the math for you.
So these opticians realized that parallax would use them,
would allow them to take images and simulate that.
I'm using a visual cue called stereopsis.
Uh,
that's one of the foundations of simulated depth that we use in all virtual
reality today is this idea of stereopsis as two separate images.
Um,
uh,
very smart English scientist,
a guy named Sir Charles Wheatstone was the first person to identify this
phenomenon.
1838 and shortly I die after he identified and he created something called a
stereoscope,
which this point it was piece of wood,
two mirrors on a 45 degree angle and two pictures on either end.
So basically the idea was you stick your face right in front of these two
mirrors.
One reflects the image over here,
the other one reflects the image over here.
And if there were slightly different images,
there's eyes would see them both at once and create that false sense of,
of stereovision.
Um,
the idea of this caught on very quickly.
A Wheatstone was an academic,
so he didn't commercialize it.
But soon after other people were like,
hey,
we could make money with this.
People would want to do this at home.
It was a guy named Brewster who in 1948 replaced the Awkward Mirror with two
prisms and because there were prisoners,
he could just put the pictures in front of your face.
The prisons also amplify the image.
If you could have much more detailed pictures.
So now you've got something that looks like a pair of binoculars.
You can just hold it up to your face,
each eyes seeing a slightly different image and you get this view of the entire
world is being a big,
beautiful three dimensional image.
A Brewster stereoscope made its debut in 1851 at the world's very first world's
fair and Queen Victoria was one of the first people to try it there.
And because she was the queen and she approved of it,
it became incredibly fashionable.
Um,
it was one of the biggest fads of that era.
Uh,
over 250,000 of those little cards with the pictures of them were sold in just
three months after that first exhibition.
Like,
it's hard for us to imagine now just how much this thing instantly blew up.
People all over Europe,
we're buying these little Brewster stereoscopes,
these little binoculars,
and they became so fashionable that it became like a luxury item saying to show
off.
Rich Victorians would buy Mahogany Stereo Mahogany stereoscopes are big boxes
inlaid with jewels and marble and stuff.
And this was like the beautiful thing that you would have in your parlor in
Victorian era.
And people would come over and they would see these pictures and they would
enjoy it.
So that's great for the Victorians.
But meanwhile,
here in the United States,
we were all about the quality,
right,
and about the proletarian populism.
So here in the United States,
a writer and a poet and a physician,
a guy by the name of Oliver Wendell Holmes,
Sr said,
well,
this device is great,
but it's for rich people.
I'm going to make the American version.
I'm gonna make one for the people.
So he made it even simpler.
He took away the whole box,
just had a stick.
Basically on the end of the stick there would be the two images that would be
combined into one stereo graphic image and too little lenses.
It's portable,
which cheap,
it was easy to construct.
It was a stereoscope for anybody.
Now Holmes was a visionary a lot of ways on one hand,
because he created this thing,
but also because he said this could be a profitable thing.
People would want to build this.
I don't want money,
I don't want to see,
I want to share this with the world.
So we open sourced it.
He took this design and just gave it away and said,
I have designed this stereoscope anybody who wants to can take my design and
produce it and sell it.
And thousands of entrepreneurs across the United States did.
So the home stereo type or home stereoscope quickly became one of the most
popular entertainment devices across the United States and eventually,
like within 10 or 20 years,
stereoscopes and American homes were like TV's in the 1980s everybody had a
stereoscope in the house if not two or three.
So stereoscopes we're a big business,
but the problem with stereoscopes is they were static and they only worked for
one person.
Okay?
Because it had to be in front of your eyes and one person had to be getting that
stereoscopic effect.
It wasn't like something you could put up on the wall and have a whole audience
yet because all of you have a different angle on this image,
so the stereopsis would work differently for every person.
The answer to that was a sort of flipped the whole idea on its head.
Instead of using two images and causing and with through the use of prisms are
mirrors of thing to merge those two images so you see them on top of each other.
This idea was let's just print the two images on top of each other to start in
different colors and then we can use colored filters so that each eye only sees
the one we want.
Now you're all probably familiar with this because you've seen the classic like
Three d movie goggles,
one green,
one blue.
That's exactly what this is.
And a graph and a glyphic 3-d is simply to images and different colors filtered
so that each,
I sees the right one creating stereopsis.
The benefit of this now is,
as you can see,
I can project one of these images on a wall.
Doesn't matter where you're sitting in this room.
If you have these glasses,
you can look at this and you see this image in three days
that led to this.
We've got static at Three d images now that we can put up.
We can put that in a stereoscope where we could put it on a wall.
This is perfect for theaters.
This was uh,
uh,
two projectors,
top and bottom,
and each one had a separate filter in it.
One red,
one green,
green,
and they would paint images onto glass slides.
This was called the magic lantern.
And they would go into a theater and set this up and you could turn on and
passed it across the room or projected image and people would wear the glasses
or hold up a little piece of,
of,
of colored paper to their face.
And it would allow them to see these bright,
vivid three dimensional images in our theater.
Of course,
they didn't move.
So this is what came next.
This is a cinema cinema octo graph.
This was created by Louis Lumiere,
who you may know as the father,
basically of the motion picture industry.
What he did was develop pictures.
Instead of having those images painted on the glass slides,
there were printed on on silos and he would make rolls of,
I'm gonna expose them.
And then the same concept,
you would have a light behind the lens,
but then crank through the images and they would display moving images.
Those same Anik glyphic colored images on a wall and went the glasses.
Now you've got three d movies.
I mean,
those caught on like crazy.
The first three d images were pretty 30 movies and stuff were pretty boring.
Um,
movies were very simple.
I'm very static.
But movies like this,
this was at the end of a movie called the great train robbery.
The outlaw just turns and shoots at the crowd.
People lost their minds when they saw this because they thought they were being
shot at like people screamed,
they ducked under their seats.
Uh,
there's another famous story of another lumiere film called the arrival of the
train of Lasagna toe,
which is literally just like a 32nd clip of a train pulling into a station.
But the camera is set so the train is pulling towards you.
And as that train came in,
people got up and bolted out of the theater because it looked like the train was
going to rip its way out of the screen.
Now that seems silly twist now,
but that was the level of immersion of the time.
Like people,
I've never seen that before and they were immersed into these films.
It was real to them.
The next sort of step course was to do the analytics and the moving pictures.
This is from a uh,
1930s film called Audio Ska picks.
This is created by Metro Goldwyn Meyer and it really,
it reminds me a lot of the very first like demos,
if you get like a,
an oculus rift or a vibe or anything else.
And like they have like the first experience that you're going to just sort of
show off virtual reality.
That's what this is.
But they ran this in movie theaters and it's literally just a series of clips of
people like pushing things towards the camera.
Like you're just this dog.
Or like,
oh look out.
There's a,
there's a uh,
a ladder coming towards your face.
Things exploding,
things popping out.
It's silly.
It's like 10 minutes long.
It's a bunch of dumb clips.
It was a huge hit.
This was nominated for an academy award
because this was the first time in human history.
People had really sat in a theater and felt immerse.
Things are actually coming towards them.
It was crazy.
So three d films kind of turned out to be a little bit of a fat at first because
they were very limited,
but they came back big in the 50s when filmmaker started actually using some
art.
And to tell stories,
you've probably seen this picture is the famous life magazine cover.
This is from the premiere of a movie called Bwana Devil Blonde.
A devil was based on the true story of guys building a train across Kenya and
these lions kept attacking all the train people and killing them.
So,
but these were actual movies with plot and not,
they had plot.
The 3d was so much more compelling because it wasn't just throwing stuff out
your face.
It was like,
oh,
I have a reason to be afraid of this lion,
which then jumps out your face.
So 3d for a period in the 50s was really huge.
It was the big thing.
Then it started to Peter out because of television.
Everybody started to have a TV in their home.
People are like,
Eh,
I'd rather stay here.
I don't want to go out.
Like this picture is tiny and black and white,
but we don't have to go anywhere.
So the film industry started thinking about,
well how do we get people to come back into these theaters?
This was one of the attempts.
This is Cinerama.
This is a giant custom screen.
The idea was this screen was so large and it curved around the audience,
it was actually filling your entire field of view.
So it's the same theory with a Vr headset.
The reason why you have that screen right up close to your eyes is because you
want the biggest field of view possible.
You don't want gaps.
You don't want to an outline because that's the,
when you start realizing that you're not where you thought you were,
this was supposed to fill your entire field of view.
But as you can see,
this is extremely complicated.
It required three projectors,
which also meant that to make these movies,
they had to have three different cameras recording each at each time.
Everything had to be synced up electronically,
both during recording and playback was incredibly complicated and incredibly
expensive.
So they only ended up installing this and a handful of theaters across the
United States,
they made less than a dozen Cimarron,
Cimarron,
a movies.
People love them when they saw them,
but it was just not feasible as a commercial technology.
It was however inspirational to certain people.
This is the creation of a guy named Morton Heilig.
Morton Heilig was a cinematographer who wanted to do something bigger and
better.
He had seen Cinerama and been impressed and was like,
wow,
I like this idea of immersive film,
but the promise with Cinerama is,
well,
number one,
even though it feels my field of the field of view,
if I turn around and look at the back of the theater,
I still realize that my theater and even that it's an a Cinerama is only audio
and visual.
It doesn't engage my other senses.
I don't think I'm in the Kenyan planes when I'm watching that movie because it
doesn't smell like the Kenyan planes.
If I'm running from it from a lion,
I don't feel like the running of adult here.
It's just I don't get all my senses involved.
So the first thing that highlight did was he built a headset he took to cathode
ray tube TVs and basically just prank them onto a headset in front of people's
heads.
Each one showing a different image through some lenses and was like,
maybe I can show movies to people this way.
It was really unwieldy,
didn't work very well.
I never really got it past the prototype stage,
but it's still to this day,
people cite that.
It's like,
well that's the first VR headset.
In a sense.
He made the first heads up display.
This was a second attempt.
This was something called Sensorama.
And as you can see,
it was kind of like a ride.
He would sit down in it.
Inside that hood was a wraparound screen.
So every way you turn your head,
you saw the image going.
It also had vibration controls.
So for instance,
one of the experiences you could watch with a guy driving a motorcycle,
and as you drove in the motorcycle like sheep,
they would shake and match up the movements it had,
uh,
in front of your face.
A little grill that would blow out smells.
So one of the little experiences,
and here was a belly dancer.
And as she would belly dance towards you,
it blew the smell of cheap perfume in your face.
But this was silly,
but it was getting more and more immersive.
Like now you're really felt like you were there.
You could see it,
you could feel it,
you could smell it,
you could hear it.
Problem was,
again,
vision was more advanced then technology and the market.
Uh,
this thing was expensive to produce.
It broke super easily.
And when it's marketed,
like the idea for this was,
let's put it in amusement parks.
Let's put it in theaters.
Let's put it on Coney island.
They literally put one in Times Square.
What happens to something left in Times Square?
That's what happened to this thing.
It was constantly broken,
was vandalized.
People cracked it open and get the quarters out.
So like it was just not a viable business and it kind of went nowhere.
Meanwhile,
it wasn't just entertainers trying to build virtual reality.
This is an academic.
Um,
the idea here is this was a heads up display.
It's hard to see in this picture,
but this has to very small,
uh,
cathode ray tubes right in front of your face.
Um,
this academic is a guy named Ivan Sutherland.
He would be famous in the story and need to appear in the story of Vr,
even if this device never happened.
Because Ivan Sutherland invented something called sketchpad,
which was the very first computer graphics software.
He was the first guy to make a piece of software that allowed you to draw using
the help of a computer,
geometric shapes and stuff like that.
So that was,
you know,
the Adam and eve of every computer aided design tool.
Every graphics program you've ever used,
sketchpads started with it.
So once he had sketchpad,
once he had a way to draw these virtual things,
he's like,
well,
how can I present that in a better display?
He wrote an essay actually called the ultimate display,
where he described where we're moving with this technology is at some point
we'll get to a display.
The computers can draw a world so real and so convincing that it will be
completely indistinguishable from reality.
Now,
it took a long while to get there and we're still not there.
But that was what he was trying to attempt here.
So we had these two a CRT displays in front of your eyes.
They were actually transparent.
So his program would draw geometric images,
triangles,
cubes,
stuff like that.
And because the whole thing was suspended,
you could move your head and the triangles and squares and stuff would appear in
the real world.
Very much like the augmented reality headsets that we'd see in the 21st century
because this thing was so big and unwieldy,
he gave it the nickname,
the sword of Damocles,
cause he always felt like it was just dangling over his head and was going to
fall on just killing one day.
But this was a really important,
uh,
a piece of hardware that got people thinking about,
Oh yeah,
I guess,
you know,
we can use computers now to create these simulated environments.
Okay.
The other group that was really paying a lot of attention to this was the u s
military.
They reasoned that virtual reality could be used to help them control the
massive amounts of information that come,
come through into,
in warfare and running a plane.
For instance.
Um,
this is something created by an engineer named Tom Sutherland who was working,
uh,
with the air force on a program to allow pilots to deal with everything in their
cockpit before he started on this,
a co pilot was saying to him,
there's so much stuff I have to deal with.
They've got all my flight controls,
I've got all the radar data,
but if I'm going into combat,
I also have all the information about my weapons.
I've got maps of where I'm supposed to drop bombs.
Like it was just too much information to deal with.
And he asked this pilot,
okay,
draw me a picture of like the ideal cockpit,
the perfect cockpit and how you would control everything.
And the pilot drew him a picture.
And the surprising thing about it was that the pilot and the picture had six
arms.
Like that was the only way to access and control of this information.
So furnace,
his idea was let's just get rid of all that data.
Let's put one of these digital displays like Sutherland creative in the sword of
Damocles and put that in front of the pilot space.
And then you can just give him the information he needs at any given time.
The same way with a computer generated rendered images.
If you're flying over target,
this thing would like give you a little dot on the ground.
Like,
okay,
this is where your target is,
could give you a little electronic Ralph,
you're a few on stuff like that.
They called this the Darth Vader helmet for obvious reasons.
Um,
this was one iteration in many of different projects,
but throughout the,
uh,
1980s and into the 90s,
this is what the US military was doing,
was trying to find a way to make this idea ever smaller and more comfortable and
get more computerized information into that display.
Late eighties and early nineties when technology becomes even more refined,
we now have better screens.
We now have faster computers.
So these are products created by a company called VPL,
with created by a guy named Jaron Lanier is actually the guy who coined the
phrase virtual reality.
Uh,
he was a very gifted,
still is a very gifted engineer.
And his vision was not just the headset,
but to really immerse people.
In the entire world.
So one of the first things,
in fact,
the thing that kind of got him into virtual reality was first he was creating
these,
these gloves,
he's data gloves with the idea of being that he was going to create a way to
control instruments using like virtual gloves.
So you wouldn't actually need a guitar,
you could just do this and it would register where your fingers were.
And then he realized,
wait,
this could also be a computer input device.
And it's sort of evolved into,
okay,
well if it's going to be an input device,
we need an interface needed to display.
And VPL developed everything from the goggles,
which were called iPhones,
e y e phones,
but still i-phones um,
they develop these data gloves.
They even had full body suits you could put on so that if you were in one of
these computer generated environments,
you could walk around the computer,
knew where you were.
If you saw a virtual reality movie in the 1990s,
I'm thinking like lawnmower man was one of the really bad but famous ones.
Johnny Mnemonic,
another one.
A lot of times,
the part where that shows up in his movies are these with VPL hardware,
those Bob,
these bodysuits.
Um,
VPL had amazing technology.
There was a big boom at the time of all my God virtual reality.
Look at this.
It's real.
It's the future.
Vpl kind of crashed and burned though for a couple of reasons.
Part of which just sort of inexperienced around running a business but also
because I think the technology just wasn't ready yet.
This was cool.
But look at those graphics in the background.
This is 1991.
Computer graphics still not Super Great.
Certainly not photo realistic.
And the processing power for the computers involved,
number one,
required massive expenditures stirs you basically needed like a supercomputer to
run this thing.
So it was not $1,000 set.
This stop,
it was more like $150,000.
Um,
and the experience was just not good enough.
And so VR started to get the reputation of,
it's a great idea,
but it doesn't really work.
We put this on,
it makes you sick,
it makes you barf.
And cause that's the recurring problem with virtual reality for these decades is
our bodies have a mechanism where if our eyes or ears or one of our senses is
telling us something that's in disagree more with our other sentences.
For instance,
if I start hallucinating,
my body thinks that I have been poisoned because over millions of years of
evolution that would is what would make your hallucinate.
You ate some mushroom that you found in the forest while you're a forging and
now you're tripping out and your body is like,
Oh God,
I'm poisoned.
I'm dying.
I'm going to throw this up so that I don't die.
That's why people get simulation sickness because these simulations are just not
real enough.
Your eyes are seeing one thing,
but your body isn't feeling it.
Or your eyes see the image and you turn your head and it takes a second for the
image to catch up.
So your body thinks,
oh,
I'm being poisoned.
And it's an unpleasant experience to say the least.
So that's why this generation of Vr kind of died on the vine.
Okay.
Then we get to this.
This is what happened in the 90s this is why we are where we are now with
virtual reality.
Two things actually.
One is the rise of smartphones.
Finally we have high definition,
bright,
beautiful,
fast,
responsive LCD screens,
led screens,
oh,
whatever you want.
Like keep getting better and better.
So now it looks more and more real.
We've also got faster and smaller processors that go into these devices and
they're being made so often millions and millions of these devices being made.
The price keeps coming down,
it's getting cheaper and cheaper and cheaper.
The sort of complimentary thing that happened at the same time with video games,
not just console video games,
but especially like three d video games,
things like world of Warcraft,
like all this sort of immersive world video games.
How are improving our computer graphics program so we can simulate,
we've gone from now sketchpad where we're just drawing cubes and triangles to
now we're drawing really convincing virtual environments.
And so the top that technology sort of set the table for the modern VR stuff
we've seen today and everything from cardboard to Oculus rift to the HTC vive.
Like all of those headsets really came out of that direct environment.
In fact,
in the book I go into way more detail about this stuff,
which is what you guys probably know a lot about,
but the very first uh,
prototypes of the oculus rift used phones,
like he was yanking phone headsets and using those screens.
So that's when enabled this modern generation of Vr to happen.
So what does this all mean?
I want to take some questions from you guys and I want to discuss this a lot
further.
But I think it,
I think the lesson from history that we get as a couple of things.
One is that virtual reality is not a novelty.
It is a new technology.
And I run into a lot of people who say to me,
come on Vr,
like it's really happening this time.
I'm sure it's not just the gimmick.
I say no for two reasons.
One is because the technology finally works now too is because this history has
shown us this isn't just like a new toy.
This is something that humans have been trying to do for tens of thousands of
years.
We finally have the ability to to convincingly simulate virtual worlds.
That's not going to go away.
The technology needs to get better,
the content needs to get better,
but I have no doubt in my mind that yes,
people are really going to want to go into a virtual world for hours for days
does disappear because it's,
it's clearly part of,
of our humanity.
Several things I think need to happen to get there.
One is hardware needs to get better screens and have to get need to get even
brighter and higher resolution processors need to get faster.
Headsets just need to get more comfortable.
Right now that's a thing like just wearing the thing on your head hurts after a
while.
So that's where you guys come in.
You'd have to work out these minor technical problems of like,
well how do we get this technology to work better and better?
But I'm convinced that this human drive,
this need to put ourselves into virtual worlds is not going to go away.
One last thing before,
two questions that I wanted to bring up is this guy.
I think you all know who he is and I think,
you know,
with the silly looking thing on his face is,
um,
Google
was a very early example of augmented reality.
The idea of being that instead of hiding your way in a virtual world,
we're putting the,
the digital objects into the real world in front of you.
This,
I was about to say in front of an audience of,
of Googlers that this was a failure.
Um,
I think that's,
that there's an argument to make one way or another.
I think the issue here was this was ahead of its time.
This was not a bad device.
It did cool stuff.
It was just too early for society.
People weren't ready for this.
And I think,
you know,
people kind of gotten to this idea of like,
oh,
going out in public like this,
your glass hole.
Just because it was so brand new,
like the ice hadn't been broken.
Well Sergei broke the ice,
so now we're starting to see more of these augmented reality headset start to
come out.
Everybody's got it on their phones,
but also Microsoft is developing the Hollow Lens.
You probably read about magic leap.
It's coming out with an ar headset later this year.
I think those are going to be in terms of business at least even bigger than
virtual reality because the benefit of augmented reality is you can do it
anywhere.
You can take it with you anywhere.
If I want to be in Vr,
I got to go to a safe space because I'm shutting off the world around me.
I'm not going to walk down the street and Vr this I can walk down the street
with and this I will walk down the street with,
especially when it doesn't make me look like a jerk for wearing it.
When it's just like a normal pair of glasses or even just like a pair of
contacts that you're wearing.
There's no reason why people don't want that extra information.
And so that's another sort of a takeaway I want to give you guys.
It's like I know that there's other stuff like this happening here at Google.
Uh,
the project tango stuff that you're doing is very exciting,
but augmented reality is just as important if not going to be bigger than
virtual reality and it's another technology worth chasing.
So that's where we'll leave it for.
Now.
I want to take your questions.
I want to talk about Ar and Vr and dungeons and dragons.
We want to talk about my first book.
Any questions come on up with chalk.
Um,
so you say that humans have been working on creating worlds that we can escape
to for the entire history of humanity.
So yeah.
Okay.
If everything is virtual reality,
then what does that term mean?
Or like how,
how,
what does that term create a bounds around that makes it still useful
to us?
It's a really important question because I think right now we have this very
sort of arbitrary definition of there's virtual reality and this reality if I do
something on a computer isn't real,
but I can tell you something.
I've done some VR demos where I went through them and I experienced very real
emotions.
It felt very real at the time and now that I've walked away with it from it,
I don't look back at that experience and say,
boy,
remember that time when I was wearing a piece of metal on my head and there were
photons being blasted into my eyes.
No,
I say,
remember that time when I Splunk through an ancient forgotten temple and had to
fight off bats with a torch,
so I remember it like it was a real experience and I think we're getting to a
point where that divide of this is a virtual reality isn't going to matter
because it was routed to me.
I experienced that
it may not have been real in the realest sense,
but it's as real as Marilyn memories just real as walking down the street here.
So,
um,
the,
the quick answer is that I think the idea of virtual reality is going to go away
and I think it will just simply be we've got different environments.
There's the physical world we live in and there will be the digital world we
live in.
It won't be any less real than this one because you experienced it and you
affected it and you changed it and it changed you.
Just this world versus that world.
Anybody else?
Hey,
great doc.
Thanks for coming.
Sure.
Um,
all the historical technology that you showed in the pursuit of creating those
virtual immersive experiences had the side effect of bringing people together
socially,
whether it was coming to the movies,
coming to the theater.
The difference with this is that that isolation aspect makes it the most
antisocial experience you can have.
What is your opinion as we start to see much more aware efforts of digital
wellness and like side effects of smartphone addiction and is ever present
technology in our lives,
how that affects us socially and emotionally.
How modern.
Yeah,
our deals with that.
Sure.
I think there are some legitimate concerns about virtual reality being a
isolating technology because you are putting on this thing that cuts you off
from the world.
I have all my VR rigs in my apartment right now.
I put on something,
I go to play beat Saber or some RPG or something and my wife is sitting there
and like she'll try and talk to me.
I don't even hear her.
I've headsets in.
I disappeared when another place that happens on a much larger scale may be
worth people who were less than happy with their real lives could sort of
disappear into this technology.
Just sort of be like,
I'm going to live in these VR things.
I think though virtual reality has much more potential for good in this area
than it does for negative.
You have to look at things like the social experiences that are being created
for Vr.
Um,
I did a demo for altspace,
which some of you might be familiar with,
which is this one of these very first very basic sort of social VR platforms.
You can log in together,
you see each other as avatars,
very simple sort of polygon will robots basically.
They don't look like real people,
but you can move around in this space.
You can talk to people.
Vr Chat is another APP like this that people use.
But like I did that altspace demo and I did it with the CEO of alt space.
I was in New York,
he was in valley.
Yeah.
And we talk to each other.
He showed me around the,
the,
the environment and we talked and at the end of it I felt like I had met the
sky.
Like I knew him even though I'd even been staring at a weird polygon on Avatar.
I hadn't even met him.
But the interaction was more physical and it just,
it,
it was much more than being on a phone call or a video chat.
And that's like generation 0.01 of these virtual reality spaces,
social spaces.
I think these tools are going to become a way for people to connect with each
other too.
You've got friends who live in different parts of the world.
You can come together in a virtual chat room.
We haven't seen each other for a while.
You actually see each other and interact with each other and socialize.
Um,
maybe you want to meet people from other cultures so you can go into these rooms
and I can hang out with people who live in Zimbabwe who I would never meet
otherwise.
It's a lot like what we're seeing on chat rooms and stuff on the internet,
but this way we actually have that physical connection.
When the systems get really good,
I can look in your eyes,
I can,
we can make eye contact.
I can see your facial expressions.
It becomes like a real social interaction.
I think that's going to be really good for people.
Another,
another common thing with the older technologies,
they all had some sort of drawback that prevented them from what you said,
looking photo realistic.
For instance.
Stereoscope is a static image.
Uh,
I would argue that anaglyph three d has loss of Koa,
fidelity.
Some people it just doesn't work right.
Sunglasses don't just work.
Right.
Um,
and yet at the same time we are living in a revival of this kind of thing at a
very large scale and yet we are still not as photorealistic technology.
So I guess the question is at what point are maybe we are already at this point
does okay,
so we've developed an aesthetic of Vr.
Is this good enough?
Could we stop and is it worth to keep going or is there value in the aesthetic
of not quite photo realistic Vr?
I think there's value in the aesthetic as you say,
of of,
of not quite VR of having a VR look like I said and things like VR chat and alt
space does not look real.
At no point do you actually think I am literally in this other place.
It's obvious from your eyes,
this is a computer simulation,
but
the experiences such and also parts of your brain are not smart enough.
They don't know what a simulation is.
Like I,
I think that the lizard part of your brain lights up in virtual reality
simulations and it says [inaudible],
well,
it looks like I'm here,
so I guess I'm here.
So you get this feeling of presence.
And in that sense,
bad graphics are good enough because you've convinced your brain enough to lose
yourself in the simulation.
Even if I'm not sort of level of higher reasoning,
you never forget that this is a simulation.
Sure feels real and experiences real.
Now.
I think we also will get to a place where photo realism and gets better and
better.
I think one of the things we promised to do there is move away from screens.
Even though screens are getting better and more and more higher resolution,
we probably are going to need something like holographic technology and are
literally beaming the photons into your eyes because then that helps with
eyestrain.
But also now you're not focused on something in front of your face.
That's one of the big problems with,
uh,
with eyestrain and with realism problems with VR right now is even though it
looks like you're looking at forest lake far away,
you're eyes are literally focused on something an inch from your face.
This whole graphic technologies don't have that problem.
And then I don't know how high tech you guys want to get here at Google,
but I am really looking forward to my direct to brain computer interface.
That's what we need is we need direct stimulation of the optic nerve we need,
you know,
that's when you get photo realistic,
that's when you get into,
you know,
the oasis,
the metaverse,
you know those worlds where it is just as real as this one.
Okay.
So it seems like for for a while like movie theaters have kind of been at the
forefront of like this kind of making this technology work for the masses.
And even now you see theaters that have a,
I think it's four dx real be three d that like you're in like a moving chair
that's there would like spraying sense at you and it's kind of like the device
it was John and talk but for a larger audience.
But it also kind of feels like there's some diminishing returns with that.
Do you think that like movie theaters will continue to kind of drive that in
terms of like trying these new crazy ideas first or is that going to come down
to like new,
smaller companies?
Um,
I can tell you that all of the big theater chains are looking at Vr.
they're looking at it in a couple of different ways.
One is that they see VR as a way to preview their movies.
Like,
Oh,
you know,
we still want to get people to pay $12 or here in Manhattan,
$19 to sit down in a seat and watch a movie.
So maybe if we released via our previews,
people will experience that and then be like,
oh,
we have to see it in person.
There are also,
there are companies saying,
hey,
maybe we just have a VR experience where it,
lots of people are in the room or in the headsets together.
Because part of what's good about the theater experiences,
the shared laugh and cry.
And so maybe if we're all just wearing screens,
as long as you can hear the people around you laughing and sign,
like maybe that'll be good enough.
I think this all comes from the fact that movies are really a dying business
because our home entertainment systems are getting so much better so than a
movie theater and movie production companies are trying anything.
Um,
when it comes to the studios and movie studios are investing big in making VR
content,
they want to transition from putting stuff on screens in theaters to putting it
on a screen in your house.
And so everybody from Fox to Sony and like all the big movie studios,
they are already making VR movies.
And they do see that as the future.
Maybe not the only way of consume movies in the future,
but a very big part of it.
Um,
and then the other thing when you talk about these social experiences that a lot
companies are investing,
especially the small sort of startup ones,
are investing in physical,
social VR experiences.
For instance,
there's this company called the void in Salt Lake City.
They have a few different locations.
There's someone Orlando,
there's one here in times square and that's the one where you wear the headset
that blocks you out from the world,
but you actually walk around a set and so there's furniture you can bump into
and there's rickety stairs you can climb.
And those things are all echoed in the simulation and that's a group experience.
It's like the one in times square is the Ghostbusters.
You all you and three friends put on headsets and you are the Ghostbusters,
you can see each other in simulation,
you can talk to each other,
but you're actually moving around and having a social experience.
And that probably is sort of the theater like experience of the 21st century.
It's yeah,
we still all want to go to a place and buy tickets and beat together physically.
But this is our way to enjoy this virtual environment together.
Thanks.
Any other questions?
Awesome.
Well,
thank you guys so much for coming.
There's books in the corner and come and talk to me anytime.
[inaudible].